on this episode we talk about
franchising we talk about open courses
we also talk about cash or exposure and
much much more you ask questions and I
answer them this is the askgaryvee show
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 62 of
the askgaryvee show
that was this alright let's get into the
show lots of stuff going on in the world
I've been super am ia in January
apologize I know we've like lost our
momentum on a daily basis the rock
always wants to shoot episodes in the
can I like to live in the real world
he's probably right I get to make the
calls
sorry Dirac by the way I've been really
enjoying all the love you're getting I
don't even noticing but every time you
get love I jump in and like try to
discredit the love I don't think that
dude what the dude was like d-roc it's
really you behind the camera that really
makes this show anyway uh just kidding
uh just kidding super happy things are
going great hustling really hard in
building vaynermedia that is why I've
been busy off the show you know for me
to have your attention I need to be
delivering on the advice I give and so
sometimes that takes me away from the
office been hustling hard with new
clients building relationships
networking CES different things of that
nature so sorry I've been a little
choppy going to Sundance you know like
so like super super choppy but we'll get
into a nice rhythm I think we have four
or five easily next week oh three now
cuz I'm going to another meeting trying
to get new client middle America Big Ups
let's get this show Harold asks Gary
what is your view on franchising your
company when you can't be sure if others
will care for the brand in the same way
Harold it's a great question I think the
real answer to that needs one more layer
of context when you say franchising your
business if you're building a consumer
facing business a retailer q sr or
restaurant then you franchising is a
tremendous model we've seen it from
McDonald's to Five Guys sonic I mean
it's a great thing to do it's the right
business model or it's a phenomenal
version of the right business model you
can go private if you want what I'm
concerned about what I don't know and
Indiana and really ask you is show India
everybody's probably missing India that
you can get the little camera time
is are you going down the route of like
selling your name the reason I'm asking
that and I don't know if you could
figure it out from the question a lot of
people tried to franchise me I know
there's a lot of gurus and advise people
where like they teach the the amount of
people that pitched me when I was out of
heat in 2010 on the idea of a Gary
Vaynerchuk crush it course and they
would be the person like teaching and
they would siphon back up to me that was
something I wasn't comfortable with
because it wasn't something that I felt
represented me and I wouldn't want to
franchise that route and so if you're
asking that
that's super uncomfortable to me
somebody representing you a big concern
of mine as far as like a retailer or a
restaurant I feel super comfortable with
that many people have pulled off you
know making sure the brand was insured
by lots of rules lots of legal jargon
lots of training or whatever it took to
scale that anything from your end you
get anything there all right so that's
the answer I give you both who cares
let's actually actually before we move
on the show I'm gonna switch it up I'm
gonna switch up the way that you have to
ask questions to get on the show me
always trying new things trying to mix
it up we're gonna shift platforms to ask
the question
Alex d/s has been in the trenches on my
Instagram so a couple of you are my beta
partners in this launch will give more
details on how to submit for the show
but I think you're gonna like this let's
go into it Sean asks Gary what are your
practical hustle hacks when it comes to
diet sleep in your daily routine
how do you maintain energy and brain
power well stop Sean I think a lot of
that comes to do personal great picture
I mean this is you know what actually
this whole picture dynamic is gonna
really flip the switch obviously you
guys know I'm super hot and Instagram to
me I care about the attention graph
actually I want to write an article a
medium about this the attention graph
that's the whole game that that actually
probably my nugget like I win on that
which is where's the attention you know
YouTube
a year after YouTube comes out it's got
attention that people don't realize is
valuable start the askgaryvee show
podcasting snapchat all right start
whine rbtv sorry for the mix-up one of
the same it's all family they're my kids
that love them both it's weirder than i
have two shows I'm like really weirded
out that I'm like gonna be a person that
has two
anyway to answer your question you know
it really comes down to loving it I you
know I
the reason I'm able to continue to
hustle and and do what I do is because I
love it I love doing the show I love
flying all over the country you know I
like taking my kind of like selfies on
Instagram or like Seth sour face and
like mmm you know and everybody's like
don't be like this is what you want
right like why are you upset I'm not
upset I'm just kind of fun little pout
face that I like to and when I travel it
not just 13 year old girls can't be the
only people left out you know
so you know I think for me it comes down
to I love it so much that it you know
here's a good answer I woke up at 5:15
this morning after landing at midnight
on a flight yesterday to play 6:00 a.m.
tip-off basketball today because I loved
it but if muscle Mike came in to like
work me out at that time I would have
been more begrudged because I love
basketball I love competition I've come
to love the working out I love the way
it makes me look I mean I've been
looking at some old videos like woo but
uh that's what comes down to if you
truly love it if you truly love it it
doesn't feel like work all these extra
hours I'm putting into the Wine Library
stuff right now doesn't feel like work
because I love the wine retail hustle
game and so it's interesting it just
comes down to love Kate Parker asks Gary
I'm growing my business and looking to
include partners for content what's the
best way to recruit them money promised
of exposure Kate I'm super pumped guys I
went to high school of Kate by the way
let me give a big shout out to Kate Kate
came to my high school junior year of
high school in the middle of the year
and Kate was a top 5 attractive girl
being very politically correct there in
our school she made huge noise Kate huge
shout out for the noise you made it
north hundred in high school 1993 and
recruited like as a soccer star by the
way just give me some naps Kate Kate you
know I've been noticing a lot of you
somebody works incredible by the way
it's been really fun to watch anyway you
know I think both work right it depends
what people are motivated by if you have
a big enough platform to create exposure
people will work for free d-roc hit me
up and offer to make a film for free for
me
because he knew that was gonna get him
his exposure he he he vetted or
intuitively felt I was a good guy sure
enough before I gave him a full-time job
offer to work here what'd you think
about that outcome but let's that's for
another day he did get into contact with
Chris bro he'll be here d-roc Brogan Ted
I mean like so so he made the right move
right like you could say wow he he did
that for free the reason I'm always
willing to take free work and free
hustle is because I feel comfortable
with the fact that I'm gonna try to pay
them back tenfold on the ROI by giving
them a shout out I know other people
that are marketing leaders pay attention
to me because I've been on a cusp of
doing new stuff and so he had all those
opportunities now I swooped in and saw
the raw amazing talent that this man had
and had to bring him on board and this
show exists because d-roc joined the
family and it gave me the infrastructure
so big shout out to you be rock so I
think three works if you think other
photographers will see value in your
platform or whatever you're trying to
accomplish money always works as well
and so you know I think people are
motivated by different things you know
some people I'll tell you something
people always try to do with me I never
do it but people do it all the time is
leveraging your rolodex I mean the
amount of people that are willing to do
things for me for me to get them to
people I don't you know I'm not going to
name drop but like it's insane I never
want to do that because I think that's
not doing the right thing for my
relationship but I understand why people
do it people do it to me left and right
the amount of like hey Gary Vee you mean
my boy Johnny McGee and then when I meet
Jeremy game he's like yeah I gave Ricky
McGee eight billion dollars to get to
you like it happens all the time so like
people value different things I think
money and exposure are two things that
actually that are we doing Patriot stuff
guys you understand I'm a weird cut guys
I'm a weird guy I'm weird I will fire
over crazy weird [ __ ] many I'm not
scared about this I'm not scared many I
fire over Patriots yet I promise
hey guys how about how do you like this
about this
like that so yeah that's it let's go on
to next questions I know you just got
taught how to submit questions and now
I'm stretching this out of even a little
bit more but let's put up five or six of
Kate's photos it's high school love fire
boy creative asks Gary I'm a big fan of
online courses I see this usurping
traditional institutions of Education in
a big way do you see this happening and
is there money to be made
what's up fire boy no quick answer to
this question is yes you know yes like
you know uber Airbnb Skillshare it's
probably one of the ones you're talking
about
there's a bunch out Chase Jarvis is
behind one yes
like I absolutely believe Khan Academy
the fact that when I'm trying to learn
something I go to youtube and search a
how-to and watch a one-minute how-to
video like information as education is a
commodity the Internet has created that
platform for us to learn that way I
don't need a teacher as charismatic as
they may be to just tell me the
information what what matters are
opinions
interpretations context not the base
information and so even here my base
information is fine how I layer the
context of the current world is far more
interesting and so I think education is
massively going to be disrupted over the
next 20 years and I think you're barking
up the right tree
Jeff this question and photo
accompanying it is probably the reason
we made this switch and this is
incredible like I'm so excited about
this I know some people like oh and so
rambly like get over yourselves let's
attack the gram with your questions um
this is a tremendous question too which
makes it even more interesting the hips
are my man is very simply like what you
need to decide is short term cash versus
long term wealth let me explain
my answer to you would be okay you're
making the products you by the way and I
had a big business at the time but like
the way I did Wine Library TV was all
encompassing myself except a Christmas
credit not videotape but there was no
editing the way d-roc it was just
uploading and in theory I could have
done that for an hour but probably not
so big shout out to Mott but you would
the decide if you want to make 30 I
don't know how long it takes you to make
one of your pieces right I would make
seven pieces instead of 13 in a year if
I can live off of that right I would do
that and I would then spend more time on
building my brand because that's really
what an artist is doing the Instagram
stuff you're doing building up your
Pinterest being smart and knowing the
world and now look at all the exposure I
mean I guarantee you I really feel
confident that one person will buy one
of your pieces from this show so you you
knew about me you you moved quit you
comment on my comments Alex hit up a
bunch of people over the last couple
days not that many replied you took the
initiative to do it now you're on the
shuttle right now you've got this
exposure twenty thirty thousand views
but you know now what you do with that
is you're leveraging that and all of a
sudden it becomes supply and demand
there are artists who make one thing up
I'm sure I'm not very strong any art
world any of you can help me here a
little bit I mean like but I know what
the answer is there's some artists who
make one piece every couple of years and
that's how they make their whole living
because it's worth a ton of money
because they've got the brand now that
you can go brand direct that's my crush
crush to talk to you so much by the way
question is literally the blueprint of
the current state of the internet I was
like I don't want to like really go
there but like I was
dick you lessly right not even kind of
and so we're all living in that world
now grape story my agency that
represents mine talent is basically the
agency of what crush it was talking
about and so it's a very simple thing
cash wealth if you decide to make seven
pieces this year and that's enough for
you to live then it makes me happy
because then you can take the rest of
that time instead of thirteen not on all
the numbers but you see where I'm going
to build your brand to engage to put out
content to write a medium post to put up
Instagram photos and that builds up your
supply and demand curve if you're
equally good enough at both if you're
equally good enough at both then the sub
demand will get to a place where you can
start charging more for your pieces to
build up your brand it's very simple
this has been going on forever
independent people have always done that
should you make pieces or should you
open a gallery should you have it should
you go hot like it's chicken and egg the
other thing to debate is can you bring
in somebody at a low cost to do it full
time and help you scale you're the only
one that can answer but guess what I'm
the only one who can answer it and right
but India's here to make it quicker for
me I do this show so India has something
to transcribe off of add some grammar
ask me a couple of clarification
questions and we've got two of the top
four posts on medium right now so you
know it all depends on how you want to
roll I had a build up to that this is
the first time I've got this kind of
infrastructure but it's just chicken and
egg you know cash flow versus wealth
there's two ways to go about doing it
you can make 13 pieces and then you're
making the money on it that allows you
to afford your person in place where you
make seven and you do it yourself for a
while it just depends on how you want to
roll but if you're not building up your
equity you're always going to be making
pieces that are hundreds of dollars
instead of pieces that are millions of
dollars and that's it it was a good show
Instagram thing you know actually let's
just go right into it I think that's the
question today question of the day give
me your feedback vaynernation on are you
excited about the you know let's do two
parter I like what you guys do to
parties are you excited about the
Instagram do you think it brings the
dynamic visually sorry podcast people
and - are you uh are you going to submit
one I'm really curious I missed you guys
a ton I've been really pumped with the
way you guys have been consuming the
content I'm glad you like the stuff that
we've been jamming on you keep asking
questions
I'm Instagram and I'll keep answering
them
on this episode we
talk about her oh crap wait subscribe I
need subscriptions because I can't push
this many right hooks in social so
subscribe